[Musica]
Buonasera Sono molto contento di essere
qui Anzi per la seconda sera di fila
e vorrei cominciare a parlarvi di queste
connessioni
moderne un passaggio del libro di cui
questa sera voglio appunto farvi
partecipe dice
così la felicità senza un felice lavoro
quotidiano è
impossibile Più che giusto di sì perché
avevo l'impressione che il vecchio mi
facesse un po' la predica Ma rispondete
alla mia domanda Come avete conquistato
questa
felicità in breve rispose con l'assenza
di coercizioni artificiali e con la
libertà per chiunque di fare quello che
sa fare meglio unita alla conoscenza di
ciò che vogliamo che il lavoro produca
devo ammettere che a quest'ultima siamo
arrivati lentamente e faticosamente
credo che però l'idea appunto che non si
possa essere felici senza una felicità
che si tragga da lavoro che si fa
quotidianamente sia proprio una specie
di motivo conduttore che tra l'altro
allinea tutti quelli che hanno anche che
mi hanno preceduto questa sera ora in
realtà Appunto questo libro di cui
parliamo è un libro scritto nel
1891 da William Morris e il il suo
titolo è news from onw cioè notizie da
nessun luogo è uno strano libro è un
libro che ha fatto scuola In un certo
qual modo e io voglio farvene assaggiare
un un po' di trama intanto dire chi era
William Morris è stato un poeta è stato
uno scrittore è stato un traduttore ha
tradotto dal greco ha tradotto dal
latino ha tradotto addirittura dal
norreno dalla lingua dell'Edda scald che
è stato un grande tessitore Tra l'altro
ed è stato pittore ancora è stato
progettista insomma si potrebbe dire un
grande umanista del del X secolo E fa
parte di quel gruppo che diede poi vita
alla cosiddetta Fratellanza
preraffaellita in Inghilterra circa alla
metà del 19o secolo Morris era nato
propriamente nel 1834 morirà nel
1896 ora questa Fratellanza per Elite
era stata ispirata soprattutto da John
raskin lo vedete qui raskin in alto Tra
l'altro ed è una cosa un po' strana In
realtà perché dentro la culla della
rivoluzione industriale cioè
l'Inghilterra e Londra in maniera
particolare comincia a nascere una
opposizione all'idea della della
meccanizzazione del mondo all'idea
addirittura della secolarizzazione in se
stessa della realtà e anche al concetto
stesso di progresso si comincia a
pensare cioè che il progresso porti in
realtà una serie di perdite una quantità
di perdite proprio nella vita
individuale e nella vita collettiva e
allora da qui comincia una sorta di
grande sogno Sogno di rium aniz Zare si
potrebbe dire proprio anche il mondo
moderno il mondo della Tecnica è una
specie di strana rivoluzione
conservatrice che nega l'idea del
Progresso e afferma quella di tradizione
e di memoria è una sorta proprio di
ripristino quindi di epoche precedenti a
quella del tempo a quella presente
ritornando anche a un Medioevo
fantastico a una cultura gotica è
strettamente intrecciata Però anche
storicamente a un certo Torno al
classicismo cosa che peraltro è tipica
per esempio del XV secolo quindi i
modelli per esempio che sono i modelli
che anche lo stesso John rasken
proponeva erano Venezia del 400 Firenze
del 400 con tutto quello che questo
significava da un punto di vista
soprattutto del rapporto fra arte e
società perché il problema fondamentale
ciò che gli artisti che facevano parte
del gruppo dei preraffaeliti oltre a
William Morris Dante Gardner Rossetti
Edward Van Jones e altri ecco il tema
era quello di riuscire sostanzialmente
con l'arte proprio a modificare la
realtà modificare il mondo grandi sforzi
naturalmente Quindi è un lavoro anche
che si porta dentro una riflessione sul
fare arte sulle arti applicate
naturalmente e che piano piano lo stesso
Morris proprio Ha tradotto anche in
attività imprenditoriali Ma cosa ne
Vediamo adesso è un poco come se tutto
questo sforzo egli nel 1891 l'avesse
proprio sintetizzato all'interno di
questo bellissimo appunto romanzo che si
chiama news from nowhere notizie da
nessun luogo
ora
l'idea del romanzo è quella di
raccontare una storia Lion arante in
realtà si impossessa di una storia di
qualcuno che rimane Innominato E questa
storia comincia nel corso di un'animata
discussione in una lega socialista nel
centro di Londra dalla quale un certo
personaggio si stacca va a prendere la
metropolitana e arriva fino al Borgo di
hammersmith sul Tamigi è un borgo
piuttosto degradato Dove appunto
l'industrializzazione produce
inquinamento quindi il contesto che ci
viene raccontato è un contesto appunto
moderno ma nel senso negativo
del termine forse questo personaggio ha
proprio dentro di sé però una sorta di
ispirazione quella di rifare il mondo in
modo diverso almeno cominciando a
sognarlo magari come diceva o come
suonava il motto già della della società
Fabiana no di rimodellare il mondo
secondo i desideri del cuore insomma
questo personaggio va a dormire e poi il
giorno dopo si
risveglia Questa è hemma Smith questa
sono i luoghi per capirci del
dell'inizio di questo punto romanzo e si
risveglia e nel giorno dopo comincia a
vedere che la stagione è mutana non è
più inverno si sta andando verso la
Primavera Ma i colori sono cambiati il
Tamigi ha un altro ha un altro insieme
di di Riflessi ci sono Insomma una
chiarezza nell'aria qualche cosa che in
qualche misura proprio fa gli fa
comprendere piano piano di essere arriva
arrivati in un altro mondo ora in questo
altro mondo che è nient'altro che la sua
casa che si è mutata appunto in una
situazione differente comincia ad
incontrare una serie di personaggi per
esempio si avvicina alla Costa del del
all la riva del fiume e li incontra un
Barcaiolo e si accorge però che questo
Barcaiolo è vestito come un uomo delel
400 Fiorentino e e comincia a vedere che
tutte le persone che sono intorno hanno
una Foggia d'abi che ricorda quelle che
io qui ho messo dai ritratti di
Botticelli ritratti del Ghirlandaio ed è
una cosa ovviamente assolutamente
sorprendente che sia venuta una cosa del
genere insomma sente che questo
cambiamento lo porta anche ad avere un
contatto con la natura vede la chiarezza
dell'acqua per esempio e chiede di poter
fare il bagno e questo Barcaiolo lo
porta in mezzo al fiume lui si immerge
nel tamig e quando emerge dal tamisi in
realtà Guarda Dove Là c'era un ponte un
brutto ponte fatto di ferro soltanto e
trova un ponte che gli sembra bello come
il Ponte Vecchio di Firenze e e questo
ovviamente lo lo sconcerta No questo è
un fatto che lo porta Evidentemente a
pensare che deve essere successo di
qualcosa di strano ecco Non è forse
questo stesso ponte che abbiamo messo
qui ma insomma sembra questo un ponte
gotico un ponte che porta dentro un
senso di Favola dici no E poi vi farò
vedere Anche perché ci sono degli
schizzi di Aldo Rossi questo strano
mondo un po' incantato che ricorda un
po' la metafisica di di di De kirico e
parlando di nuovo con il Barcaiolo Dice
ma dice ma questo ponte Da quanto tempo
esiste ah dice l'hanno l'hanno
inaugurato L'hanno scorso cioè nel
2003 Cioè lui scopre di essere nel
2004 quindi il salto incredibile che è
avvenuto in questo tempo lo ha portato
Appunto nel 2004 dove sono avvenute
queste cose straordinarie e in questo
contesto di cose straordinarie incontri
si susseguono uno più bello dell'altro
la casa in cui viveva è diventata una
specie di Locanda dove ci sono delle
donne molto belle Tra l'altro tutte
molto disponibili e molto legate agli
uomini più da rapporti di amicizia che
d'altro Ecco un po' come se ci fosse
proprio questo spaccato vedete in alto
dipinto famoso di Dante Gabriel Rossetti
a destra in alto le tre grazie di Edward
Van Jones insomma È come dire tutta la
pittura rafaelita che viene descritta da
Morris Appunto e i contatti anche con
queste donne Sono sono molto semplici
sono contatti dati proprio anche dalla
franchezza si capisce che si potrebbe
comunicare anche sessualmente con queste
donne stando sullo stesso piano e Però
lui si sente sempre più a disagio
infatti gli chiedono Da dove viene
perché ovviamente lui non potrebbe
essere di quel tempo no E quindi lui
dice ma sono uno straniero e da quel
momento in poi viene cambiato il signor
ospite e poiché questo signor ospite fa
tante domande e naturalmente gli si
vorrebbero dare delle risposte il
Barcaiolo che gli racconta di aver fatto
quella scelta di fare il lavoro perché
quella verso cui si sentiva portato e
tanti altri presenti lì dicono la stessa
cosa si offre di portarlo a Londra a
incontrare un certo vecchio che gli
racconterà tutto quello che succede in
quel tempo Infatti è bellissimo questi
contesti che vedete qui riportati
appunto queste donne eccetera su una
bella carrozza trainata da un cavallo
bianco questo Barcaiolo che si chiama
Dick porti il signor ospite verso Londra
Ecco È una bellissima gita che viene
fatta e tutti i luoghi che erano i
luoghi scuri plumbei della Rivoluzione
Industriale sono rifioriti come vedete
in questi spaccati è come se si fosse
ricreata una civiltà fatta di piccoli
vill villaggi come se non ci fosse più
il senso della Metropoli come se non ci
fosse più il senso di tutto ciò che è
connesso strettamente ma In un certo
qual modo si fosse creata una situazione
di anima di
respiro tutte le descrizioni che Morris
fa in questo libro richiamano molto
appunto per esempio Lo stile Che Antoni
Gaudi ha usato a Barcellona le case
Vedete qui alcuni esempi appunto famosi
di case di Gaudi è chiaro che poi quella
poetica preraffaellita si è espansa in
in Europa e dove voi Vedete che le
connessioni forte sono fra stili diversi
come se si vedesse la presenza della
Persia la presenza appunto
del della civiltà Bizantina no E tutte
quante le memorie si sono legate in uno
stile in cui tutto in un certo senso
comcia bellissimo è poi il senso proprio
della riforma del lavoro nel senso della
felicità della comunità e non c'è più un
mercato Aggressivo ma c'è uno scambio
delle merci ciascuno si sente
consumatore e insieme produttore quindi
c'è questa dimensione proprio di riforma
dello stare al mondo Diciamo pure in una
dimensione di amicizia e insieme di
amore queste mani molto belle disegnate
da Dante Gabriel Rossetti sono le mani
di Dante de Beatrice Non a caso perché
chiaramente anche in questo senso c'è un
richiamo fra l'altro proprio a la figura
stessa di Dante Ecco e sono descritti
poi tutti questi edifici e insieme a
questi edifici poi compaiono anche donne
bellissime come queste che vedete
dipinte proprio da Dante Gabriel
rossetti e quella al centro è proprio
Jane Morris tra l'altro è
la moglie è stata la moglie di William
Morris e anche qui però per una grande
liberalità di rapporti in realtà c'era
un Menager TR famoso appunto i i tre
Appunto appunto praticamente convivevano
e convivevano inizialmente nel Kent in
quella Red house che Morris Fa costruire
che fosse proprio il primo crogiuolo di
quello che possiamo considerare il
design moderno Poi ci saranno anche
altri luoghi ecco Ma vedete il mondo
Sostanzialmente è è questo e Ecco i
luoghi che vengono descritti poi
appartengono anche alla vita di Morris e
quello che vedete sotto sono proprio i
prodotti che Morris il quale Fra l'altro
è un uomo che disponeva di molti soldi
appunto ha potuto far costruire o
costruire in alcuni laboratori della sua
Morris and Co che viene fondata nel 1861
a tradurre proprio questo sogno di
riforma del mondo di rifare il mondo
anche nella vita quotidiana quindi nelle
sedi nei tavoli e in tutto quanto tra
l'altro poi effettivamente la morren co
aveva un negozio a Londra aveva una
quantità peraltro anche di di
commissioni produceva Tra l'altro famosa
carta da parati che è stata appunto poi
celebre nel mondo La cosa curiosa è che
con tutte queste contaminazioni che si
ritrovano ci sono state in effetti poi
delle conseguenze lunghissimi se mi sono
sbarr dito a vedere per esempio quanto
Kubrick in 2001 e nello spazio per
esempio riprende a curiosamente proprio
nell'astronave un disegno che è proprio
di un interno progettato da William
Morris o come peraltro un'altra figura
che risente tanto di questo tipo di
contaminazioni sia stato David bowe
forse David bowe è stato l'ultimo
preraffaellita si potrebbe dire no in
questo c'è tutta la dimensione anche di
una di una dimensione sessuale
particolare Ecco anche qui ci sono come
dire dei dati interstiziali delle
comunicazioni quindi credo che sia stata
una forte spinta appunto che Morris ha
dato e che questo libro in particolare
riflette Londra appare totalmente
trasformata in una città giardino Dove
sono state salvaguardate soltanto
proprio le vestigia gotiche Quindi come
l'abbazia di Westminster Ecco e tutto
respira adesso a rovescio si potrebbe
dire rispetto alle chiusure della
Rivoluzione Industriale proprio in un
moto si potrebbe dire opposto Salvo la
British Library cioè il British Museum
che è rimasto e dove il nostro Morris
cioè il nostro in realtà signor guest
incontra il vecchio Hammond che è quello
con cui parlava all'inizio e che gli
diceva che non si può essere felici
senza fare il lavoro che dia felicità e
che gli racconta poi tutto quello che è
avvenuto e come sono cambiati gli usi
come sonati i costumi la parità fra
l'uomo e la donna naturalmente Quindi
tutto un insieme di elementi che non
producono propriamente un mondo del
tutto felice ma un mondo che tenta
proprio di tener Fede allea dimensione
umana per cui la donna magari si lega
alluomo Poi però può separarsene
liberamente e viceversa E allora si pone
il problema dei figli però al tempo
stesso nessuno è punito per avere
abbandonato la famiglia Cioè ci sono
tutta una serie di elementi appunto che
fanno pensare anche a un possibile
miglioramento e le vesti Naturalmente
sono quelle sempre che ci rimandano
appunto al 400 Fiorentino con tante
varianti Vedete qui per esempio di
fianco un dipinto proprio di Edward B
Jones dedicato alla propria figlia sulla
destra ora hemmond racconterà al nostro
al
nostro signor ospite quello che è
successo non tutto è andato così bene in
realtà racconta che alla fine del 900
c'è stata una tremenda guerra civile che
ha opposto il capitale al lavoro una
guerra cruenta che però a un certo punto
è stata risolta perché le due fazioni in
lotta si sono messe da d'accordo a
cominciare dalla salvaguardia del
patrimonio culturale e hanno In un certo
qual modo stipulato i primi armistizi
pensando proprio di salvare la
tradizione dell'arte Cioè come se l'arte
fosse stato il linguaggio che hanno
cominciato a riparlare proprio per
superare quel conflitto tremendo che si
era creato appunto fra capitale e lavoro
anche questo è un fatto progettuale E
allora ecco che ci sono degli architetti
per esempio che hanno e
ridisegnato proprio la Londra che il
nostro Morris ci fa vedere dopo questa
guerra civile quindi dopo che si sono
risolte le questioni vedete che è
proprio Londra e questo è il panorama di
una Londra di un'inghilterra appunto
risanata attraverso il rapporto con la
natura la cosa interessante è che in
realtà questi non sono soltanto dei
sogni perché se io torno rapidamente a
Barcellona e vado a vedere questo
ospedale della Santa Croce di San Paolo
proprio costruito dal dall'architetto
Luis domenic i Montaner È come se mi
trovassi all'interno di quella Londra è
come se in un certo senso ci fosse stata
anche là una applicazione proprio di
questo principio E questa sintesi Forse
questa idea legata molto
all'individualità la poi ripresa davvero
il nostro architetto Aldo Rossi nel suo
Teatro del mondo che è una specie di
sintesi di questo news from nowhere
almeno da un punto di vista
architettonico che è diventato poi
l'emblema si potrebbe dire di queste
connessioni che si portano addirittura a
livello planetario Ecco il teatro del
mondo forse questa è la vera
individualità forse questo è il vero non
luogo questo fosse è il modo anche
giusto credo per passare dalla dal
Villaggio Globale a quella che mi piace
chiamare la globalità dei dei villaggi E
questo forse anche un modo un invito
a guardare quello che noi abbiamo già un
modo per guardare quello che abbiamo
forse dove siamo stasera è come se In un
certo qual modo potessimo
attraverso le news from nowhere tornare
a casa e riguardare riscoprire con la
memoria anche il luogo stesso nel quale
ci troviamo Dunque direbbe TS Elliot not
far Well but far Forward voyagers non
Buon viaggio ma avanti viaggiatori
[Applauso]
Grazie